you just about broke the internet with
your post why was it so important and
just fulfilling for you to join this
franchise um for me it was I've always
thought about honoring my dad and just
because it's such a big part of his life
and my life of course I was just waiting
for the right moment and I wanted it to
be something super small and simple that
was almost like an Easter egg like if
you didn't know who I was you wouldn't
even notice it because I know that's how
my dad wanted me like my dad was very
humble very simple so I thought like the
best way to sister would have this like
very special moment that was quite sure
but like left my little Mark and I could
always share that with him so I have
never been with this cast that there
hasn't been a nod to your father and hit
talk about how he you know is forever
family do you feel like these guys are
your family and you're forever yes I
mean I I go to them like with everything
I mean I live with Jordana when Kobe
first broke out I flew from New York and
I was living with her in L.A for a part
of lockdown and Ben was out of there
Jordan they're all at my wedding so
absolutely I think the family thing is
definitely very real and they really did
see me grow up so I feel like we all
have because I remember when we used to
see pictures of you and you were so
young and now you're married my life has
changed a lot yeah it's special for you
to be here tonight I was just talking to
John and of course you interact with him
a lot and he was like I was so excited
to work with her and she was um amazing
I I know I mean I heard like Louie uh
the director gave me like some comment
of like seeing an actress be born later
today and all these things and I was
like I don't know who I did that well
but I was honestly very grateful to be
in the scene with John because he was so
patient and so kind and like obviously
he was extremely nervous I didn't have
to take any classes of any prep I was
just like okay everyone let's do this
and I was like shaking and the part of
the scene I had to like hold things and
like they were just falling all over the
floor and then he was like did someone
like get some super glue and like then
he like to change it and he and then he
was like kept reassuring me he was like
don't worry we have all day like because
I was like I feel so bad like I'm
messing everything up and Louie the
director of the same they were both just
like we have all the time that you need
so how did it come about did Vin call
you and say I want you to be in the
movie or
um actually it was it's a thought that
I've had for a little bit like even when
nine was swimming um and I I mostly
spoke to my my dad's best friend Brandon
about it and I was like I think that
obviously I spoke to Van about it too
but but
um I just was like I wanted you in a
very tasteful way and um I think Brandon
and then you know collaborated with the
universal and we got that perfect rule
for me so I love that have you seen
yourself yet have you seen them I
wouldn't even look at the playback when
we were filming I have not seen I think
I'm the only one here that has not seen
the movie because everyone keeps
commenting on it I'm like I don't know I
don't know what my scene is like yeah
I'm a bit scared but like
um I definitely like I'm really excited
about my my part but I know your daddy
would be so proud of you and you know
he's here in spirit with all of us
tonight for sure congratulations
thank you